einsamkeit ist ein tabu ein persönliches
problem aber auch eine gesellschaftliche
aufgabe
die betrifft alle menschen je nach
situation die sie mir auch noch passiert
das finde ich besonders bitter
großbritannien wird sogar politisch
aktiv denn chronischer einsamkeit tut
weh mit messbaren folgen für die
gesundheit
sie hat enorme auswirkungen schlimmer
als rauchen bluthochdruck fettleibigkeit
oder luftverschmutzung was sonst im
fokus steht können wir etwas tun um das
soziale miteinander zu stärken
[Musik]
hallo ihr leben mit bin auch jetzt da
vor sieben jahren zog ihren gürtel nach
münchen um in der nähe ihrer tochter zu
wohnen
andere kontakte in der stadt hatte die
rentnerin nicht ich habe zwar schon hohe
einen eierlikör lebkuchen und einzeln
schnecken mini da meinte dieter beese
den letzten biss sie diese backstube
entdeckte
hier setzt ein junges start up auf back
omis als back profis wir haben alle alte
gute rezepte die wir doch gerne
weitergeben möchten nicht nur an unsere
eigenen kinder sondern an die
allgemeinheit sonst geht es ja immer nur
in der familie weiter und das macht spaß
jung und alt arbeiten hier hand in hand
tatkräftige rentner sind das herz der
backstube für ihren gürtel viel besser
als alleine zu hause zu sitzen
etwa 80 kuchen entstehen an diesem
vormittag theresa offenbach schätzt das
potenzial der bug omis und back office
und den generationen mix es kommen
menschen zusammen die sich sonst nicht
begegnen
ich glaube dass die gesellschaft in der
wir leben das total unterschätzt also
dass alte menschen nicht wahrgenommen
werden dass man sich keine zeit für die
nimmt kann man überlegt wie viel zeit
ich mit alten menschen gespräche und es
ist auch meine familie ist das im alltag
überhaupt niemand
20 prozent aller menschen über 85 gelten
als einsam knapp zehn prozent sind es
bei den 65 bis 75 jährigen aber auch
fast 15 der 26 bis 35 jährigen kennen
das schmerzhafte gefühl
oertel trifft mit alten rezepten und
jahrzehntelanger back erfahrungen den
geschmack der zeit die reeser offenbach
organisiert die abläufe und schaut dass
in der schicht alles läuft ganz
besonders beliebt oma ihren karts
karotten kuchen
der versand über das internet und 20
münchner cafés sorgen derzeit für den
nötigen absatz erfinderin und
jungunternehmerin katharina meyer setzt
auf beschäftigung ohne alters schranken
was wir ja klar sehen können ist der
demografische wandel das heißt 2040 wird
so sein dass mehr als 40 bis 50 prozent
der gesellschaft über 65 jahre ist für
mich persönlich ist es wichtig dass man
gesellschaftliche herausforderungen auch
im wirtschaftlichen kontext und konzept
angehen kann das nicht immer ein verein
oder eine stiftung sondern dass jeder in
unserer gesellschaft verantwortung
übernehmen kann und das auch ganz normal
im arbeitsumfeld in der backstube sind
die ersten kuchen im ofen als nächstes
muss sich ihren garten nun um die
eierlikör torte kümmern
es ist nicht so dass ich nur ständig
unbedingt unter menschen sein muss man
also ich hab auch ruhig sagt so jetzt
ach wie schön mal ganz will niemand
etwas von mir ach das ist herrlich aber
auf dauer kann ich mir das nur krank
machend vorstellen
[Musik]
christian ads weiß wie sich einsamkeit
anfühlt er zog vor sechs monaten nach
studium und promotion in den norden
gucken was habt ihr denn hier schön ist
doch eher so was hier das motto gefällt
mir sehr schon kommst heute für 50 in
hamburg fand christian ads den ersten
job seine freundin lebte hier
dann war schluss und er allein weit weg
von freunden und familie
ich komme aus einer kleinen stadt mit
20.000 einwohner und ist so einer großen
stadt ist halt das sind so viele
menschen aber man kann sie ja schon
lange verliert man sieht halt viele
menschen aber werden sie trotzdem nicht
kennen uns ja trotzdem einsam und
vielleicht noch ein sagen wir es so
viele menschen sind anders als in der
heimat bei tübingen ist er hier jetzt
auf sich allein gestellt
[Musik]
als außendienstmitarbeiter trifft der
32-jährige im job selten kollegen ist
ständig unterwegs sein zu hause eine
einliegerwohnung außerhalb der city in
einem viertel in dem mehr familien als
zehn leute finden man fange ich doch
ziemlich auch so auf dem sofa rum abends
wenn ich nicht so richtig wusste oder
halt nicht die kraft aufgebracht haben
oder wo treffe ich leute oder wo finde
ich den leuten einsamkeit bedeutet
unfreiwillig allein zu sein
das subjektive gefühl dass die sozialen
beziehungen nicht ausreichen
[Musik]
christiana dies will das ändern ein
online portal bietet die möglichkeit
kennenlerntreffen in einer
überschaubaren runde erst mal meldet man
sich im internet an
mit der app pony friends traut sich
christiana die stars dating macht man
heutzutage auch online dachte ich wie
sowieso nicht und ich meine ja ich denke
da kann es mal ausprobieren und für mich
vor zwei perfekt sein welcher halt viel
unterwegs bin und dann auf dem weg
vielleicht einfach manche wie christian
ads leben viele in single haushalten in
deutschland sind es 41 prozent
spitzenreiter in europa ist schweden mit
51 prozent während portugal gerade mal
auf 22 prozent kommt
singen flexibel für die karriere online
vernetzt das moderne leben kann
einsamkeit fördern
jeder zehnte in deutschland kennt dieses
gefühl man dann nur so kleine ist dann
grübelt man halt dann ist dann schon so
ein bisschen depressiv würde ich sagen
wenn ich einfach fehlende kontakt
christian ads wagt den schritt von der
online anmeldung bei der freundschaft in
die reale welt
heute wird er wildfremde menschen
treffen zum burger essen und
billardspielen an zumindest eins aber
dann auch dahin zu gehen ist ein anderes
trotzdem hört mal losgeht sich trauen
wird er heute neue freunde finden
[Musik]
auch ältere männer sind von einsamkeit
betroffen über dieses gefühl zu sprechen
oft ein tabu das ist auch in mansfeld
dem männer schuppen im englischen
führung nicht anders wenn du das bewegst
entstehen immer neue form
deshalb greift der leiter des men's chef
patrick adams in die trickkiste
wenn man zwölf männer über 65 in einen
raum setzt und ihnen sagt redet über
euer leben eure gesundheit eure
beziehungen und sehnsüchte dann
verlassen sechs den raum und die anderen
sitzen rum und sagen nichts stellt man
aber einen kaputten rasenmäher in die
mitte und sagt die jungs repariert das
dann wissen alle nach zwei stunden was
die anderen können wer sie sind und auch
alles andere ganz nebenbei entstehen
kontakte und gespräche wichtig für
menschen wie williams denn je länger
menschen sozial isoliert sind desto
schwerer finden sie den weg zurück in
die gemeinschaft
ich bin ziemlich schüchtern
als ich das erste mal hierher kam öffnet
sich die tür ging rein und alle haben
geguckt es ist wie in einem pub gehen
und alle ständig an gott aber alle
sagten hey komm doch rein
wir lachen viel und reden über gott und
die welt
wir brauchen zwei minuten um den break
sind wieder in ordnung zu bringen
einmal die woche hierher zu kommen das
gibt mir ein ziel
man muss nicht kommen man kommt weil man
es wirklich will und weil man leute
treffen will
der männer schuppen ist nur ein bauteil
eines großen netzwerks gegen einsamkeit
in form
juli carey downs spielt in dem netzwerk
eine schlüsselrolle und bringt menschen
zusammen das hat sich auch das neu
gegründete britische einsamkeit
ministerium vorgenommen und will
initiativen wie diese in form stärken
ich glaube auch leute die arbeiten
würden wirklich gerne kommen nach der
arbeit sind manche doch ganz schön
einsam
juli carey downs ist health connector
also eine gesundheitsberaterin sie
vermittelt zwischen ärzten patienten und
den vielen angeboten gegen einsamkeit
indem wir die leute im ort mit ins boot
holen haben sie das gefühl dazuzugehören
niemand gibt anweisungen sondern als
teil der gemeinde fühlt sich jeder
verantwortlich
und so beteiligen sich die menschen viel
eher an unseren aktivitäten und das
beugt krankheiten vor
denn einsamkeit erhöht zum beispiel das
herzinfarkt oder schlaganfall risiko
deshalb ist die 55-jährige täglich im
einsatz um überall in form menschen auf
aktionen und angebote aufmerksam zu
machen
[Musik]
gemeinsame aktivitäten als
gesundheitsvorsorge highlands julie na
wie geht's gut und die super danke ich
habe einen aushang gemacht und flyer
ausgelegt
auch supermarktmitarbeiter lanz london
gehört als ehrenamtlicher zum netzwerk
erhält die augen offen erkundigt sich
nach dem wohlbefinden seiner kunden und
weist als community charakter also als
gemeinde berater auf die zahlreichen
angebote hin fällt ihm etwas auf gibt er
es an die gesundheitsberaterin weiter
die fast 600 ehrenamtlichen community
connector unterstützen die sieben
festangestellten hälfte nektar die
wiederum stehen im engen austausch mit
dem ärztezentrum das ärztehaus in form
vor sechs jahren entsteht hier die idee
ärzte und soziale angebote miteinander
zu vernetzen
[Musik]
hinter dem engmaschigen system steckt
die ärztin hellen kingston
das netzwerk wird dauert erweitert
mittlerweile gibt es 119 angebote
es wäre prima sie alle auf einer website
zu haben
es ist nicht so einfach die angebote zu
finden das stimmt die beiden frauen
optimieren das netzwerk ständig sie
helfen scheuen patienten angebote
wahrzunehmen
ihr ziel den teufelskreis aus isolation
und krankheit durchbrechen
ppn doggen kreis menschen geraten
seltener in gesundheitliche krisen und
kommen nicht so oft ins krankenhaus
das ergebnis wir haben weniger teure
notfalleinsätze und damit geringere
gesundheitskosten und tatsächlich drei
jahre nach start der
gesundheitsinitiative war in form die
zahl der aufnahmen in die
notfallambulanz um 14 prozent gesunken
während sie in den umliegenden
ortschaften um 28,5 prozent anstieg
[Musik]
bei chronischer einsamkeit schüttet der
körper vermehrt cortisol aus das
stresshormon schädigt den körper auf
dauer herren kingston arbeitet hart
daran das zu verhindern
als teil dieser gemeinschaft beschäftigt
mich das was hier passiert ich kenne
meine patienten sehr gut ich bin hier
schon seit über 20 jahren wenn man sieht
wie menschen die einem nahestehen leiden
dann versucht man instinktiv dinge zu
verändern und er auf die bedürfnisse
einzugehen
für die gesundheitsberaterin steht noch
ein hausbesuch an
wie geht es dir evelyn ganz gut meine
hände sind kalt allein kaum ist 99 jahre
alt und kommt ursprünglich aus london um
nicht allein zu sein zog sie nach rom
zur familie ihrer tochter
ehemann verstarb bereits vor 31 jahren
im moment ist also alles gut kann ich
irgendwas tun
nein ich denke nicht vor einem jahr
starb dann ihre tochter an krebs im
alter von 73 jahren
er wurde in köln zog sich zurück wollte
niemanden mit ihrer großen trauer
belasten
gesundheitlich baute sie immer mehr ab
[Musik]
versteht mich was passiert und warum man
weiß nicht wie man das verkraften soll
ihr besorgniserregender zustand viel den
ärzten auf das netzwerk griff ein
seitdem kommen die gesundheitsberater
regelmäßig zu besuch
jemand außen stehen das kann dir helfen
man kann reden die tränen auch mal
laufen lassen tun wonach man sich fühlt
damit geht es ihm viel viel besser
das war wirklich wie ein rettungsring
kann ich dich sonst noch unterstützen
brauchst du irgendwas kann ich leider
nicht viel tun
ein projekt gegen einsamkeit das
vielleicht bald in ganz großbritannien
schule macht
[Musik]
hier das da das ist das erste und zwar
müsstest du da bis 15 uhr da sein
in der backstube des jungen start up
sind inzwischen die ersten kuchen des
tages fertig zum ausliefern
irmgard oertel und die anderen bug omas
und opas sind im schichtbetrieb im
einsatz
[Musik]
ihr arbeitsplatz regelmäßiger treffpunkt
für back fence mit der chance kontakte
zu knüpfen die über die backstube
hinausgehen
[Musik]
wir schauen dass die wir uns sehr gut
verstehen besonders gut verstehen dass
wir auch in der gleichen schicht sind
und dadurch sind ja auch schon
freundschaften dann entstanden und die
eva maria dem fahrzeug am herzen und wir
warten mit liebe diesem zusammenhang die
wellenlänge stimmte sofort zwischen
irgendwo und mir das passte
mittlerweile verbindet die beiden eine
tiefe freundschaft welche menge nämlich
jetzt die 80 jährige macht an diesem tag
11 kuchen in handarbeit
für 17 bis 35 euro werden sie später
verkauft ganz umsonst machen wir es
nicht
ja es ist nicht so doll viel aber es ist
der minister
wir bekommen ja und das ist natürlich
ein zubrot
ich muss ehrlich sein jedes leben in
münchen mittlerweile kommt dass jeden
monat verschwindet pro monat rund 200
euro zur rente dazu verdienen ist ein
gewinn
der größere wert ist aber ihre neue
freundin heute darf ich mal direkt mal
eilig für lebkuchen machen den habe ich
ja noch gar nie gemacht
ich kann probieren
[Musik]
nach vier stunden ist die schicht vorbei
doch statt jetzt die füße hochzulegen
spielen die beiden back thomas auf
gemeinsam karten und genießen ihre
gewonnene freundschaft
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
auch dabei ramin at er ist einer der
gründer der freundschafts ab und hat das
treffen organisiert nicht allen fällt es
leicht die scheu vor dem unbekannten zu
überwinden von 20 angemeldeten sind am
ende acht tatsächlich gekommen
ich habe schon grundsätzlich dass es
nicht so mega sexy zu sagen ja ich muss
jetzt meine freunde benutzen
aber es ist dass sich ein gerades
problem dass viele leute haben dadurch
dass wir halt dass in den gruppentreffen
machen und versuchen das natürlich sehr
natürlich zu machen ist sie schaum
gefüllt hab ich ein bisschen geben sie
verloren und dieser schutz der gruppe
ist halt ein wichtiger faktor dafür dass
leute auch gerne solche veranstaltungen
kommen spielerisch kontakte knüpfen
die meisten teilnehmer sind wie
christian ads zwischen 25 und 35 mal so
langen beziehung und auch die freunde
der damals alle verloren
so einer großstadt ich wegen leute kürze
werden großartige ist echt schwierig war
die app recht gut
ich hatte schon leuten erzählt oder wenn
halt was machst du auch wenn ich sage
ich gehe hier billardspielen burger
essen und dann ja mit wem und wo er mit
wildfremden menschen man muss am anfang
also small talk sowie ins gespräch
kommen aber wenn es dann läuft dann
läuft sie auch also war heute ganz klar
ob für christian ahlers aus diesem
treffen freundschaften entstehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sebastian link ist soziologe aus hamburg
als mitverfasser einer studie hat er
untersucht inwieweit soziale kontakte
von armut beeinflusst werden
er ist in berlin auf dem weg zu einem
nachbarschaftstreffen in einem
mehrgenerationenhaus
die einsamkeit gerade in berlin ist ja
in ordnung sich mal so das kann ich in
allen schichten beobachten und in allen
altersgruppen ob das jetzt die älteren
menschen sind die jetzt einsame das
leben weiter gestalten die dann der
taxifahrer der einzige ansprechpartner
ist innerhalb von zehn minuten oder die
lebensgeschichte erzählt und ganz
schnell
weil die zehn minuten sind schnell oben
aber wie hängen einsamkeit und armut
zusammen
armut in unserer gesellschaft wird
zunehmend als individualisiertes problem
dargestellt
hier spielt selbstverschulden eine immer
größere rolle
wenn das der fall ist dann müssen wir
uns glaube ich darüber bewusst sein dass
armut auch ein phänomen ist das mit
sozialem rückzug einhergeht mit
schamgefühlen einhergeht und dass das
natürlich auch die sichtbarkeit der
armen menschen reduziert die studie
zeigt nach zwei jahren in armut sinkt
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sich
betroffene mit freunden verabreden armut
verschärft also das risiko einsam zu
werden
als arm gilt wer weniger als 1100 euro
pro monat zur verfügung hat die
kreuzberger sozialarbeiter tim in saal
und carla miranda kennen mensch mit
finanziellen sorgen hier im kiez deshalb
bieten sie kosten günstige kurse an
heute findet der kochabend cooking with
friends statt
besonders betroffen von einsamkeit durch
armut rentner menschen mit
migrationshintergrund und
alleinerziehende ein bafög ich hoffe
auch sonst hat sich die keine staatliche
unterstützung für den keller seite ich
bin darauf angewiesen wäre selbst
bearbeiten und es nicht einfach mit zwei
kindern menschen denken oder so etwas in
der art
und hier wirklich auch mal wieder mit
einem gewissen blick um wieder den
kontakt zu kochen auch mein kind
mitnehmen zu können dass es tatsächlich
eine bereicherung
gemeinsam statt einsam veranstaltungen
wie diese helfen schamgefühle abzubauen
und den zusammenhalt zu stärken weiß der
soziologe ich gebe etwas zutrauen
vielleicht drückt was hier auf die beine
zu stellen was die die menschen hier
gemacht haben und was ganz stark und
nicht das mitnehme im fokus stand
der schritt ist das abbauen von
barrieren und ein angebot für alle zu
schaffen
solche orte und begegnungen sind
notwendig besonders für menschen mit
wenig geld
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber einsamkeit ist überall auch in der
reichen gemeinde zug
[Musik]
judith fischer ist der
nachbarschaftliche kontakt wichtig die
selbstständige juristin unterstützt maja
momentaner gerne im garten regelmäßiger
austausch erhöht nachweislich die
lebenszufriedenheit die hilfe der über
20 jahre jüngeren judith fischer sorgt
auch dafür dass ihre nachbarin fit
bleibt zum teil ein bisschen erde oder
so was was man geschaffen muss und da
ist irgendwie ihre volle kraft herrn
bisschen jetzt wenn ich mir so hinter
lage das zu stemmen und ich arbeite sehr
gerne ausgleichs halber im garten oder
wach selber ein garten und dann haben
wir uns gefunden und es ist eine
wunderbare frau zur seite steht
das wird judith fischer nicht mit geld
sondern mit der investierten zeit
vergütet die sie ansparen und wiederum
nutzen kann wenn sie selbst hilfe
braucht es ist ein geben und nehmen
es gibt ein sicheres gefühl für beide
sie ich weiß ich kann in urlaub fahren
und jemand guckt für meinen garten und
sie versteht auch was davon man sieht
und gleichzeitig umgekehrt sie weiß dass
wenn irgendwas ist kann sie mich anrufen
[Musik]
und es ist leichter hilfe anzunehmen im
wissen dass die geleistete zeit dem
anderen auf einem zeitkonto
gutgeschrieben wird
dahinter steckt die organisation cas
ob autofahrten reparaturen oder
spaziergänge wer hilft kann den
geleisteten zeitaufwand für eigene hilfe
ansparen menschen werden so
zusammengeführt das bestenfalls
freundschaften entstehen
das hilft gegen einsamkeit und das
zeitkonto ist gleichzeitig eine vorsorge
strategie fürs alter noch dazu wird der
staat entlastet und der eigene
geldbeutel susanna fast wind ist die
treibende kraft von kiss kiss ist eine
abkürzung keep it small and simple und
das heißt wir wollten eine kleine
organisation machen vor ort wo die leute
sich kennen und zimpel also ganz einfach
in der handhabung da haben wir uns ein
bisschen getäuscht von der
steuerbefreiung über das einsammeln von
öffentlichen geldern bis hin zum ausbau
der software
all das ist aufwendig für susanna
fassbind aber die idee vom heilsam
miteinander geht auf das interesse an
einer vermittlung von gesprächen durch
kies lag im vergangenen jahr sogar noch
vor dem bedarf an hilfeleistungen im
alltag der soziale zusammenhalt am
boomenden wirtschaftsstandort zug leidet
unter den ständig wechselnden
arbeitskräften aus aller welt
dass auch die karriere einsamkeit
fördern kann weiß judith fischer aus
eigener erfahrung ich war jahrelang
eigentlichen top management von großen
unternehmen tätig war die erste einzige
staatsanwältin in graubünden ich war die
erste einzige sicherheit zur
verkehrspolizei chefin in st gallen so
das ist immer mit einsamkeit auch
verbunden mit seinen eigenen weg machen
und einfach entscheiden müssen
ich kann gut allein sein ich habe
größere reisen gemacht ganz allein durch
die welt ich habe keine furcht oder
sowas aber dass freude teilen können
fehlt dann die 55 jährige hat das gefühl
von einsamkeit als warnsignal verstanden
um ihr leben neu zu ordnen
vor drei jahren hat sich die juristin
deshalb selbstständig gemacht mehr
selbstbestimmung eine neue partnerschaft
und das engagement bei kiss haben ihr
leben bereichert ich weiß nicht wie
viele generationen lang das überhaupt
bestand haben wird darauf verlasse ich
mich natürlich jetzt in dem ich gebe und
davon konnte eigentlich zeit an spare
aber ich bin unglaublich auch positiv
überrascht wird dass sich ausweitet dann
durch sich das verbreitet und ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass das irgendwann
einfach zurückgeht einmal im monat das
große miteinander decks gemeinschaft
13 orte in der schweiz kopieren das
modell bereits auch wenn es von den
organisatoren und teilnehmern einigen
einsatz erfordert eine tolle
gemeinschaft und von der es lohnt sich
wirklich auf solche angebote zu
studieren und sie das ernst und
anzunehmen nicht in sicht auch zu ziehen
genauso sind tausche zeit gegen zeit ist
eine idee mit zukunft die auch
ausserhalb der schweiz gelingen kann
[Musik]
auch christian ads hat initiative
ergriffen und damit einen treffer
gelandet
röslers trinken der kapitän hatte was ja
en zu tragen oder ja ich habe meinen
bruder abgeholt dann einfach zu fahren
den 30-jährigen terence medco hat
christian ades bei einem der quali
friends treffen kennengelernt sie haben
sich auf anhieb gut verstanden weiß auch
schon immer schon sind die persönlich
hat jetzt nicht mega viele freunde schon
immer eher so ein paar aber dann richtig
gut und sowohl die sind ja also auch
einordnen
zum thema freundschaft ist es dazu denke
ich dass ich schon das gefühl haben
möchte also vertrauen zu haben ich habe
zu vertrauen und das ja dass man dass
man verlässlich ist und das andere
verlässlich ist und wenn man dann
sozusagen selbst sich auch mal traut
dann dinge anzusprechen die einen dann
selber beschäftigen oder will man da
vielleicht auch leichter
dank einer app einen fremden zum freund
gewinn für den neu hamburger ist das
konzept voll aufgegangen
das gefühl schmerzlicher einsamkeit wird
er jedoch so schnell nicht vergessen
ich denke mal dass wir hinterher immer
das positive rausziehen kann einfach
nicht ihr sagen wie man das dann erst
wieder wertschätzt wenn man dann sieht
nicht mehr so alleine fühlt also
praktisch schon nach dann einfach wie
schön ist und wie schlecht ist einfach
davor ein praktisch aber dass merkel das
dann noch
neue freunde suchen und finden sich in
netzwerken engagieren und anderen zeit
schenken
das lohnt sich für jeden einzelnen und
für die gesellschaft
[Musik]